So now that we have seen how the BTB and the BHT work together, let's do a BTB &
BHT QUIZ on that. Suppose we have the following program. This is
the address of the instruction. This is the
instruction itself. And these are the labels for
branches. So, what this program is doing is
it's moving 100 into R2; it's moving 0
into R1. And then as long as R1 and R2 are
different, it's going to continue here. Once R1 and R2 are the same, it's
going to jump to the Done label and exit this loop. In the loop, it's adding
R1 to R3 to form R4, uses that to load a value from that
address and then adds that R4 to R5, adds 1 to R1 and
then unconditionally branches back to this loop. So this is the loop. This
is where we exit from the loop. And this is the sort of initialization for the
loop. Suppose that we have a branch history table that has only 16 entries
and makes perfect predictions about branches. Suppose
we also have a BTB with 4 entries.
Also makes perfect predictions. And as you can
see, all instructions are four bytes in size, and
we know that. So the question for you is,
how many times do we access the BHT for
each instruction? Right here, how many times we access
the BHT with this address because we are fetching
this instruction? Here, how many times we access the
BHT with this address because we're fetching this instruction?
And so on. There are eight instructions here for each one of
them. We need to say how many times we access the BHT.